théo berne à présent lorraine présenté
ses lucioles par sa mère sem présent
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une fosse
salles de classe de la marque et on est
dans un studio de vigan de coquillages
et on va aujourd'hui faire le premier
opus l'académie des camps
[Musique]
nous sommes ici réunis autre camp que
pour passer quelques épreuves attendent
pour passer quelques épreuves qu'ont à
définir la des épreuves qu'on peut
retrouver vraiment en cours aujourd'hui
l épreuve qui sont à moins que y'a pas
du tout en cours il y aura quatre
épreuves le but bien évidemment c'est
d'avoir les meilleures notes à la fin de
chaque épreuve pour à la fin de la vidéo
à voir la meilleure moyenne générale et
gagner ton carnet la bouche à la benne
non non non mais s'il vous plaît quoi à
chaque manche on a le droit de tricher
pour avoir la meilleure note aussi un
exemple je peux copier sur mon voisin je
peux lui demander des petites astuces je
peux etc mais attention dans toutes les
manches
même si l'épreuve est différente ce sera
toujours sous le regard aiguisé d'un
professeur certifié de l'académie de
versailles c'est pour sentir mon jeu ce
qui est de la prod ce moment il faut ce
professeur a droit de nous retirer des
points s'il nous prend la main dans le
sac et le cidre a nommé des blâmes et
une fois qu'on arrive à 3 blâme
on est punis au coin pendant une minute
donc ça pénalise notre équipe pendant la
manche en cours les équipes vous l'aurez
compris ce sens m et lorraine contre
théo et lucas on commence tout de suite
avec la première épreuve la dictée
bonjour à tous je suis le professeur
winston et je serai votre professeur
aujourd'hui
bienvenue à tous dans ma classe je veux
bien vous fassiez des petits chevalets
avec vos noms de famille vu comment vous
êtes nombreux comme ça je vais
comprendre plus facilement qu'ils vous
êtes merci beaucoup
alors mademoiselle je vois pas super le
décaler un peu ok lucioles vous à côté
de vous il ya monsieur poubelle
monsieur poubelles et enchanté monsieur
kouyias et théo le rigolo si chers
élèves
nous allons commencer par la toute
première épreuve qui sera une dictée
bien évidemment vous ne copiez pas les
uns sur les autres je veux pas entendre
parler qui que ce soit et en garde son
sérieux et la dictée sera bien
évidemment noté turcs ont bien monsieur
le vent ce sera contée dans la moyenne
oui donc on commence première ligne
alors que ses cris comment alors alors
que le crépuscule pointer le bout du nez
trop vite alors que le crépuscule
pointer le bout de son nez en sang des
les attendait oui enfin oui
vous voulez alors que les crépuscules
pointer le bout de son nez virgules
espace jeux attention monsieur poubelle
le petit enguerrand s'égosiller face à
son écran points
monsieur kouyias attention jour pas
encore une fois c'est moins 1 le ghana
n'a jamais refait c'est toujours moi
après moult essais vers le saint graal
oui bien sûr c'est pas ça j'attends un
coup de fil en fait tu peux t'attendre à
koffi l'important oui bah écoutez le
coup de fil va attendre ici vous allez
vous installer il se dégage un tricheur
vous êtes vous à traiter de [ __ ] moisins
derrière dernier pas entendu mais
n'utilisait plus le terme suggère jamais
distincts donc après moult essais vers
le saint graal mais déjà dit pardon et
si vous n'arrêtez pas de me couper je
peux être continuée le procrastinateur
se trouva fort à chaque fois lorsque
l'électricité brusquement se coupe à
monsieur théo vous vous croyez vraiment
discret prochaine foire est ce que ça
coûte pas moi j'ai ouï oui regardez
aussi non mais après l'électricité
brusquement se coupa point à la ligne
vraiment attendez retourner votre et
juste pour voir on va retourner là ok -
en plus j'avais mis plus vraiment je
suis nul
-2 à faire vite et vous voulez en un
autre moine on s'adresse le jeune glissa
de son trône et atterrit avec fracas sur
son coq si ce monsieur
non ça abusé quoi mais regardez on
entend que monsieur loyal et j'ai reçu
un micro
le tableau est d'ailleurs quatre mois de
plus vous mangez
non moi pourquoi oui cela crée peut-être
oui à cette moyenne on se voyait jeu
mais là c'est une heure de colle je
regardais heures de colle mais si vous
avalez non mais j'ai aimé monsieur oui
je me fait ça tout seul
oui c'est nul est-ce que la techno est
fini tu viens pour berges du papier la
bulle est vraiment avoir zéro terrain
theo le rigolo monsieur parent déjà
quelqu'un qui parle peut-être venir
déjeuner en justice si je me retournais
carrière vous avez pouces - 3 bons il
est parti est-ce qu'on vous rend les
copies wii n'est en axant suis en train
de corriger
désolé tyson j'ai bien entendu ce que
j'ai en tête
monsieur kouyias je vais vous mettre
votre premier blâme et au bout de trois
blâme je vous sors du court mais j'ai
ouï m'a proposé des chiffres pas vous
dire ta gueule fin c'est elle qui
retombe de gens parce que déjà pas si je
suis témoin tue mes chiens à la clé
c'est comme un jeu d'argent alors moi je
rentre dans le jeu direct par des jets
vite avec des chips vous préviens juste
si jamais je trouve des chips quelque
part la personne qui les aura un blâme
je vais vous rendre vous recopie on va
commencer par la plus nulle jusqu'à la
meilleure c'est un connard
bah 12e blâme au troisième blog vous
sortez mademoiselle lucioles
vous avez eu 10 sur 20 avec et -3 que
j'ai mis sur votre copie ça vous fait 7
sur 20 c'est la plus mauvaise note pas
la rouille et vous allez venir au
tableau pour m'écrire parce que vous
n'avez pas écrit sur votre copie coccyx
mais ce n'est pas fini et tu peux finir
non non mais c'est 10 min non ta tombe
la bombe sale gueule comme ça il vient
dire sa tâche de gala vaut déjà monsieur
il a un paquet substantiel quoi ça
semble parler d'un dossier de théo le
rigolo non mais c'est pas moi mais je
vais la mission ma chaise mais pas du
tout dans cette bataille c'était pour
faire une blague
j'étais prêt je vous ne savez pas
l'écrire n'ont plus envie non ça finit
par un x oui oui [ __ ] donc sa selle
c'était de la merde tout comme votre
copie monsieur kouyias vous avez eu 12
sur 20 mai avec vos deux points de malus
vous avez dit souvent c'est bien j'ai la
moyenne ça ouais vous pouvez m'écrire
s'égosiller sais c'est pas un concours
où l'un en dessous de l'autre côté vous
voulez vraiment que je vous met en place
et aurait décidé de le disperser
oui il m'a acheté un papier si tu me
vois pas monsieur tian g7 un deuxième
lame bas vous allez vous asseoir mois -
chez crest coccyx bas et alors ça fait
quoi ça te faire dans la vie grâce
monsieur il a fait une faute au coccyx
ah oui par là bien sûr il a écrit coccyx
thé xx voilà et je dirais entre l'utopie
en souvenir merci ensuite en deuxième
copie nous avons théo le rigolo
évidemment qui a eu 14 sur 20
mais avec ces -4 de malus 10 / temps et
qui a gagné du coup monsieur pierre
gagnier qui a la meilleure note de la
classe c'est monsieur poubelle j'ai eu
14 sur 20 mais qui n'avait que deux
points de malus qui attend qu une note
finale de news of the world les moyennes
générales sont pour votre équipe 10 sur
20 voilà la n205 exhale et pour votre
équipe neuf émissions
elle donne aux les amis je le rappelle
nous sommes ici avec notre jolie 10 si
vous êtes avec votre navire 5 tout est
rattrapable deuxième épreuve qu'est ce
que ça va être avec l'épreuve de las las
erbakan un métier - lab histoire cette
épreuve est extrêmement compliqué il
faut être très discret je vous explique
nous allons tous les quatre avoir une
cervelle cannes à air comprimé
professeur wilson aura une cible scotché
dans son dos le but est très simple
pendant qu'il écrit au tableau il faut
envoyer des projectiles au plus proche
du centre de la cible
l'équipe qui aura envoyé plus de
projectiles sur la cible remporte la
manche agression est discret les blâmes
peuvent tomber je le rappelle c'est
votre pote pendant une minute il peut
rien faire quand vous avez trois blagues
nous on est déjà de chacun dans la mère
m'ont bien oui mais ça passe ça y est
c'est parti les points de la 6ème à
cannes comme en ce moment
[Musique]
alors chers élèves nous allons
maintenant passer aux verbes irréguliers
en espagnol on va commencer par carrière
qui veut dire tomber
ok alors qu'ailleurs et messieurs je
peux aller chercher maccoll si vous fait
votre quoi backhaul ça colle elle a
glissé mais analyse alors qu'air caire
tu veux dire tomber c'est cadeau ksk et
ensuite nous avons d'arbres qui veut
dire donner dab nom d'homme c'est un
mouvement de danse et d'art donné ça
donne toy d'amos thaïs on a ensuite le
verbe qu'on utilise souvent des six qui
veut dire dire oui avec 10 go 17 10 go
au sein d'ibm anigo c'est un verbes
irréguliers
d'accord je ne savais pas je voulais
qu'on me suis pas fait tomber quelque
chose oui ça c'est mon micro je suis
désolé démission si on n'a pas grand
drame d'un micron chemin interdit un
blâme au oui voila merci compass est
stable
c'est le verbe être et caceres star donc
c est oui
bien
estas stars adorent j'ai fait tomber ma
colts à clapton non maccoll je suis pas
alors on va maintenant passer au verbe
acerbe qui est le verbe faire donc c'est
à gossau si la candidate heures à fait
franche pas comment ça marche pas bien
l'espagnol j'ai toujours eu un problème
avec os il veut dire entendre auriez
moss
oh oui layar blâme qui parle est un blog
qui parle j'ai vu des élèves faire des
choses j'ai vu lucioles j'ai vu à quoi
je vous ai vus jouer vous allez au point
commence à jouer en troisième place en
eurocoupe installés au coin pendant une
minute
mais j'ai rien fait je me suis alors
quoi penser quoi vous avez dans le
pardon c'est quoi ça sert ouais vous
allez laisser votre bureau pour monsieur
vous métaux quoi est ce que vous pouvez
écrire pour moi les prières personne du
singulier
ok alors j'ai entendu un truc qui
connecte nancy lorraine et c'est moi qui
ai fait ça même si on a le verbe s'avère
qui veut dire savoir qu'il ya c'est sa
baisse donc c'est écrit comme ces tests
avec un peu accès backhaul c'est courir
en cours de jeu vous avez un deuxième
blâme au troisième vous allez entendre
votre pote théo le rigolo il en est qu'à
sont conviés à son deuxième ballon on a
après le verbe ça y est c'est vous dire
qu apporte t vous êtes au coin vous y
restez pardon ou rester au coin qui
hurle un trio très très très moche
restreint on ensuite le verbe valeurs
que dire valoir de balgau balès bas les
balais mosbah les baleines baleine c'est
marrant c'est un peu comme slimane
baleine bah ouais il nous reste deux
verbes bénézis geenen
[Musique]
car ôter le coin voulait rester au coin
avis en fait monsieur et en plus ils se
marrent bas vous allez bientôt vous
marrer quand j'appelle les parents voilà
ce que vous avez oui imminente
il est il est derrière nous dans qu'est
ce que vous comprenez pas dans le moment
points vous avez tout compris
l'écriture datango elle est par contre
c'est à dire 20 ans qu'on n'a pas fait
quel verbe kaberle et en plus une
particularité quand on l'écrit c'est
qu'est peau etc et pau ça s'écrit q q
vous avez des questions ou tu es parfait
pour moi ok c'est ben voilà on a fait
tous les ans julien basset la fin de
tête tu peux revenir du côté haut
[Musique]
alors vous avez compté combien de fois
vous avez touché comme hélas pour nous
de quatre membres vivent leur fils qui
est pas fous toi combien de chaînes
n'ont aucune toi non je crois que j'en
ai mis pareil quatre mois après je
touche et là là là là ok on a gagné la
première manche au tie ex-aequo donc à 2
1 pour nous tout est possible il reste
deux épreuves je le rappelle dans cette
épreuve
c'est un peu comme avant c'est l'épreuve
de discrétion vous connaissez les
cartouches vous connaissez les
cartouches d'encre vides est ce que vous
connaissez les cartouches d'encre vides
qu'on colle au plafond moi je connais
cartouches l'animateur je connais mais
j'ai jamais faites nous sommes dans le
même cas on donne des trucs de kant ne
fait pas ça en cours vraiment mais c'est
un peu un fantasme j'ai jamais osé le
faire encore jetés là il vous est
honteuse
le but c'est de coller le plus de
cartouches trop plafond donc vous
l'envoyer comme ça ou alors vous
l'envoyer avec votre rêve alors vous
vous démerdez nous compterons combien de
cartouches il ya au dessus de chaque
équipe est l'équipe qui aura envoyé le
plus de cartouches au plafond gagnera la
manche bien entendu troisième manche
c'est parti les premiers cartouche on y
va à led zoom sur winston lemay vous on
ne commence maintenant
mes chers élèves oui passer au courant
des verbes irréguliers en bout des
doigts non je suis de l'ombre à vous est
temps de crise
monsieur kouyaté au contrat du pid
monsieur oui si je peux me permettre
très bonne mine
c'est gentil non c'est un processus et
il est français par les cantines ou non
monsieur kouyias on se tait s'il vous
plaît j'avais l'air de pardessus sombre
ou si on va commencer par le web ou qui
y est se réveiller se réveiller
broken nose lucioles c'est encore
d'humour en cours dans la nièvre et
pauvre prof angoulême c'est un wake bâle
2e verne je pense que vous le connaissez
cbi le berre ben ali c'est moi c'est
avec ce but was when the world comme le
gps théo le rigolo oui monsieur je
ramasse un papier où et n'importe quoi
oui c'est un blog monsieur vous pouvez
réussir votre bureau prenant ensuite le
verbe arrêté vite sa vie n'est plus à sa
place je veux pas être désagréable
il a un truc à un poignet demander ce
qui a dans les mains vides c'est ça
colle à 6 mais totalement de la faire
tomber
pourquoi vous avez votre colle alors
qu'on fait de l'anglais monsieur poulat
que vous avez en troisième lame
clairement que vous allez prendre la
place de monsieur kouyaté aucun souci
monsieur je ne conteste pas ça me va je
peux pas me permettre de retrouver comme
vous le trouvez rapidement à vous le
mettez sur votre bureau dans les six
livres j'empêche plus le cours hockey
lna
attendez vous allez vraiment rester
longtemps et vous vous asseyez vous le
sauriez défendre
la langue anglaise n'est vraiment pas
sûr c'est vraiment rigolo mais vous avez
un blâme non ça fait genre prennent fait
une fois et des deuxième lame on a le
verbe mordre sur le rigolo vous allez
clairement à ce coin comme je vais donc
écrire notre verbe sur le tableau qui le
verbe bytes
[Musique]
je trouve que ça ça joue je comprenais
quoi dans au coin monsieur théodore
hiblot sortir du court mais c'est mon
tube de colle que je cherchais partout
vous avez une cartouche d'encre coller
sur votre bras donc je vous exclus pour
secours et vous nous rejoindre au
prochain merci monsieur rigolo où on va
mais si ces messieurs vous écrivez que
moi habitent ce genre est de 3
j'aurais préféré avoir écrit au tableau
mémoire peut-être si voulez je peux
l'écrire ça me fait travailler mon
exaucé n'hésitez pas à les surveiller
quand même parce qu'ils monsieur énergie
fut avant beatles ebit mais j'ai rien au
jeu des plus gros et
[Musique]
la csq
j'ai vu mon coin je lève mon conscient
de la lexus est court à personne bassil
non seulement vous me donnez regardez
comme elle ment ça dégage vous revois en
train de sourire
elle sourit elle sourit je veux finir
d'écrire biten elle sauver nommé
regarder la série mettant en sourire au
visage normal 707 rockwell et ne rien
dire monsieur oui je trouve que je suis
seul
ce que je pourrais me retourner en quad
dont il est resté on a le verbe gros je
vous écris tu direct l'aller je veux pas
d'expliquer d'où sortait mai prochain
j'allais vous proposez vous avez été
malgré tout les plus sages dans cette
turbulence de l'est pouvoir retourner au
bureau et on va faire court dans le
calme et bien sûr qu'on va passer au
verbe split manai si toi tu as donc mais
je sais entre mohamed était donc c'est
split comme un banana split
ensuite on a stand to dust and stone
stout
ok le dire je tenir debout car c'est ce
que vous faisiez il ya quelques secondes
prochaine fois vraiment prochaine fois
aujourd'hui vous en verrez peut marquer
les 3 ceci je les ai pas bien en tête
mais maintenant les trois verbes westens
vous êtes quoi stijn stijnen surtout
hockey pouvait marquer les 3 alors on à
monsieur j'ai une question
oui très rapide oui pourquoi il est bien
sûr le bac gris gas vous êtes exclu du
groupe et vous reviendrez au prochain
court en étant bien plus calme dans
quels projets vous pouvez arrêter de
faire ça bien sûr bon vu qu'il n'ya plus
de membres de l'équipe numéro une
on peut en conclure que l'équipe numéro
deux a gagné cette manche
sport 2 2 c'était la pierre blanche de
l'histoire de notre équipe
exactement ses armoiries du début à la
fin et j'ai essayé de rattraper comme je
pouvais en raclant plafond cela va
marcher dessus d'une balance non j'ai
une question quand le prof siby thème il
s'accordait mais en fait comme si
régulier je les cieux après je suis
presque convaincu par ce qu'il est en
train de dire c'est plus fun unique
d'ailleurs sa gueule dernier l'épreuve
on change de thème n'y aura pas de
discrétion quoi que ce soit on va partir
sur une épreuve que vous calé cette
vidéo avait fait dans votre vie une
épreuve d'acrosport chaque équipe va
choisir trois figures dans un pdf ya des
figures simples des figures moins simple
des figures très dur des figures en
russie plus c'est dur plus la figure
vous rapporte 2 points à l'équipe qui
aura eu le plus de points grâce à ces
figures remporté la manche on commence
maintenant c'est parti
acrosport tatamis c'est maintenant
pour cette épreuve d'acrosport veuillez
accueillir la première équipe composée
de lucioles et poubelles est la deuxième
équipe est composée de monsieur kouyias
et monsieur théo le rigolo vous avez
vous à faire de sport non c'est moi je
fais 10 par an jean ba vous avez un peu
de mal juste le nom même est donc un
poids en moins sur le résultat final
vent ici nous avons énormément de finir
chacune d'entre elles est très difficile
à assumer lorsque vous la fait sachez
que pour valider une figure vous devez
la tenir trois secondes vous désirez ici
donc mais figure bleus sont les plus
sains elles valent 4 points bien les
quatre principaux le fait une fille
n'est pas mal du tout les figures vertes
sont un peu plus difficiles par exemple
celle ci six points quand vous vous en
faites une figure orange 8 points là on
est sûr a dit ward quand figures rouges
aïe aïe aïe dis moi mais c'est pas
possible non c'est pas possible
elles sont très compliquées un petit
défilé des figures les plus compliqués
manar sur vos écrans
[Musique]
c'est mme lorraine je vais vous donner
ses feuilles
vous allez avoir quelques minutes pour
choisir trois figures la difficulté bien
sûr réside dans le fait que si vous
visez les figures à 10 points mais que
vous ne faites pas vous perdez une
finale des points sur la paix est une
figure blog vous réussissez vous gagnez
4 points ça vous revient à laisser votre
figure et on vous retrouve après
quelques instants ces pavillons
alors on va commencer avec un basique
une bleue à wayne bleus mais genre à une
mise en bouche donc là la laddh et à 0 2
seniors real 0 d'or m'est avis aux
futures crises
deuxième c'est dur ok de la mer nous
emmener coup c'est de la merde ça
continue ils essayent de faire ça dans
la dernière du côté est une rouge bien
un truc un peu on retourne aux bleus
c'est quoi
je tombe pas messi mais c'est aussi la
plus minime
oui monsieur vous êtes prêt mais on
n'est pas rien réussi on vous regarde
[Musique]
quelle fin
figure numéro un deux trois six grands
numéros une vallée de 4.6 dieu sait quoi
des scènes filmées row 2 les chais
vaisseau baptisé cool voilà bon bah
voilà troisièmes tentatives dans combien
de tentatives en avoir parce qu'on sert
tellement drôle chrétiens ont une forme
troisième tentative
allez on tente une dernière lorraine tu
donnes tout dernière sentence est pas
mal vous êtes de mauvaise foi un arrêt
sur image avec la fusion vas-y c'est sa
garde et au dessus des 3 à ses biens
alors nous avons choisi une figure verts
et deux figures orange
et oui car on aime le risque même dire
pourquoi acteurs vous n'êtes pas humble
il a raison il a réellement la première
figure et celle ci trois secondes faut
que ce soit beau comme ça oui oui
travaux par ex ce sera beau farès
deuxième figure d'ailleurs pas vu et
enfin la troisième qui est peut-être la
plus difficile
êtes vous prêts ouais mais nous allons
les faire dans la suivante ouverte
orange orange
pierre débauche benjamin millepied
[Musique]
à un deux trois six points séparent on a
besoin faire tuer fuite des auteurs
vas-y ça semblait pressée d'avancer rien
ne te rendre plus que ça m'arrive de me
faire rire
[ __ ] quand on était prêts ont fait
l'otan fait le tirer mais c'est une
porte d auteuil le ta jambe
il faut que ces bases il à séduire la
couette et pathé o asie c'est maintenant
tu me tiens d'excès en l'air vas-y c'est
maintenant on en propose une figure pour
remplacer celle ci si jamais vous verrez
monsieur wilson si on a des ponts pas
c'est gratuit
on a fait comme ça attention
mais la blague en fait
[Musique]
on vous rassure partie du show ça finit
toujours comme ça vous avez bien réussi
la meilleure figure qui était verte dont
qu'il vous rapporte 6 points voilà après
vous en avez réussi aucune mais pour la
prise de risque
je propose de vous rajoutez 2.6 vous
ferez arrivé à 8 points ce qui ferait
égalité cependant parmi vous une
personne n'a pas ses affaires de sport
matata grillage un point en moins pour
son équipe ce qui amène à 16 secondes ce
qui fait donc que l'équipe de lucioles
et poubelles sont les grands gagnants à
un point près juste à cause d'une tenue
oublier anna merci c'était une très
belle compétition merci pouvait loin
vous remercie lorraine c'est rigolo
c'est super bien je suis désolé moi
j'aimerais acheter un duo avec le
absence de cette vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé cette première
édition de l'académie des cons
[Musique]
j'ai pris énormément de plaisir ça
faisait longtemps je voulais faire une
vidéo dans le délire des cours parce que
mine la phrase de vue attention ça me
manque un peu quoi les années lycée tu
sers ça m'a fait très plaisir de tourner
avec vous les amis vraiment gros plaisir
n'hésitez pas à pas savoir leur chaîne
youtube a passé voir n'hésitez pas à
nous dire ça vous a plu et on fait
d'autres épisodes avec d'autres épreuves
des épreuves bien évidemment différente
et il y aura le retour de monsieur
winston je peux encore le chat ça me tue
on sait tous maintenant j'aime prochaine
vidéo merci à regarder au revoir
l'académie compte fermer ses portes pour
le moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]